hey what's going on a spill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
just checking in on you oh Jesus Christ
uh you know what you know what I could
really use right now a [__] nap I
just realized that I'm getting into my
old man nap so the old man the old man
anyways I am here in New York City I
worked on the movie today we did a great
scene or two now I came back and I just
missed my lovely daughter she was going
out to some frigging class she had
really [__] broke my heart if I was
gonna get home in time to see it but
she's back at six o'clock so I'll get to
hang with her tonight
cuz what's more important than that oh
you know what making you laugh in this
moment as you [__] trudge home but
either way everybody please try to be on
the lookout for cyclists out there you
know 16 people have already died riding
bicycles this year alone in New York
City I cannot [__] believe that if
you get on a bicycle in New York City
with all these [__] people driving
around texting while driving while you
on a bicycle blow off as many [__]
red lights and stop signs as you can can
you [__] believe people that died in
these [__] [__] on their bicycles
god bless them you know you gotta like
them on one level because you know
they're keeping themselves in shape
they're not polluting okay they're
thinking globally they're acting locally
and all that type of [__] haven't said
that they had a big protest you know to
try to make safe for bike lanes which I
agree with but I'm a [__] so I got to
give them some [__] they [__] down
there and that they had a big thing
where everybody laid still in honor of
the dead 16 [__] people this year in
Washington Square Park and they're
blaming the government and they're gonna
the governor saying he's not doing
enough and he doesn't give a [__] about
cyclists did they ever bring up day you
know something nah we could probably do
a better job stopping at red lights
instead of gliding through weaving
through traffic all that dumb [__] that
they [__] did what was the last time
you saw somebody on a bicycle actually
stop and there's supposed to you know
they love to act like they're a [__]
car when they're riding out in the road
and you got to go 10 miles an hour
behind him second there's a stop sign
all of a sudden they they [__] go
right through it I kind of like they're
a ghost of some [__] that's the thing
that bugs me is that the thing well one
of many things people on motorcycles
another [__] thing they always think
what can these these things where people
pull out in front of people on
motorcycles so we wake the [__] up wait
the [__] people can't see you you know
it's dangerous you know what you signed
up for not saying it's not fun I'm just
saying how about a little bit of
responsibility to get how many times
have you been in a car and you saw
somebody guy go by in a motorcycle and
you just like that guy's gonna [__]
die
I'm literally looking at a [__] dead
man maybe not right now maybe not
another mile but eventually that person
that they continue to ride like that
they're gonna [__] die I can't tell
you much times I've been like driving
down the highway and somebody comes
blowin by me so [__] fast on a
motorcycle actually scares me like a
[__] human missile lots of prayers go
out too
that's all I'm saying cuz I'm all for
the bike lanes I wish they had him I was
actually talking to the guy bringing me
back from the movie there in the van and
I was saying like you know in the future
when they look at these bike lanes where
there's no barrier between where the
cars drive and where the bikes are
people gonna look back and just be like
Jesus Christ it's like looking back in
the day when a goalie didn't wear a mask
you know well you look at the original
like those those Formula One races from
the 1950s with this footage and on a
straightaway they just have the crowd
standing on the grass behind a rope
they'd have them like 20 feet off and
it's all good because they're thinking
whether they're going straight through
here until two of them bump into each
other sending each other both out into
the [__] crowd
that's all I'm saying I don't know I
grew up in an era when you wrote a
bicycle you didn't wear a helmet and you
wrote on the sidewalk you didn't ride
out in the [__] Street like you were
having your own bike race that nobody
knew about and if you died on a bike
that was it nobody spray painted it
white I mean nobody even knew I don't
think but I mean I don't know I'm weird
on this bike issue like I think it's
great more people should do it
it's got to be safer but like these
[__] I'll say conservatively that
twenty to thirty percent of people on
bicycle ride ride like [__] and
don't stop at red lights and that's only
that's saying what two out of ten three
out of ten and that hasn't been my
experience I Drive my wife nuts um but
I'll be in the car just really he's not
gonna you know and blame [__] people
in cars and anyway sorry anyway let's go
to something positive the women's soccer
team went back to back in World Cups
championships first woman's team to ever
do so when they had the parade today in
New York City so congratulations to all
of them are they gonna go for a
three-peat you got to go for a
three-peat has that ever even happened
in men's soccer I don't know you know be
awesome is if soccer becomes such a huge
sport that there's a professional
professional league that women's support
the way men support the NFL and [__]
they buy jerseys and [__] and then these
women go out and make [__] million
dollars you know get commercial [__]
whatever what he called endorsement
deals and all how great would that be
that would be so [__] it would be
great for women and it'd be great for
men because they quit trying to worm
their way into our sports
I cannot stand women in male sports
why because I'm sexist probably but
besides that I just don't like how when
they show up all of a sudden like the
whole [__] thing has to change to the
way they want it they can't even just
meet us halfway like alright we'll try
to tone down some of the locker room
language but you know you got to get a
little more of a tougher skin it's like
no I feel [__] triggered this is my
space and I need you and they see you
know everybody's wearing pink for a
month in the [__] NFL [__]
intrusive [__] I'll tell you what's
killing me is I'm reading I'm reading
that Ken Stabler [__] book right it's
just that though that those days just
don't exist anymore where a guy could
get divorced twice and still have enough
money to get married again just doesn't
exist back to any bit all right I'll
give you a [__] cow the pot dishes
and a pat on the ass you can go [__]
yourself I'm keeping the cat while I'm
building I bailed the [__] thing they
know all that goddamn right I did all
right emotional support doesn't build a
structure you know you don't have those
divorce settlements anymore anyway I'm
[__] I'm overtired here people but if
I don't do this podcast now I know
tomorrow I'm gonna have an early call if
I do the podcast now tomorrow I will
have a late call at which point I'll get
to sleep in which is something I'm
really looking forward to so I know the
show business gods are like I know you
don't so I'm trying to just go on
momentum here my modem so once again I
think what I was just trying to say is
congratulations to the women's soccer
team and it's a great thing for ladies
everywhere and I think it's it's high
time that they had their own sports
leagues separate but equal
[Music]
why can't you just let us be morons over
in our own little corner can't we just
do that can't we just do that jesus
[__] christ
Jesus Christ honey I don't even know
what I don't even know what anymore I
don't get out joining something that
oppressed you that makes you stronger
why don't you create your own [__]
thing and then you run it right
isn't that the stronger move is that the
brave move I have no [__] idea by the
way we did a show in Staten Island at
this beautiful theater I didn't even
know existed anyone you know I didn't
get the [__] name of it
theater Staten Island Michael Bolton
says he was playing there coming up what
is it what is it the st. George Theatre
oh my god was that place [__]
gorgeous I didn't even know it existed
you know it's weird as I came down to
New York City you know it started coming
down before I moved in 1994 so it took
me 25 years to finally get to Staten
Island and do a stand-up show down there
and an incredible theater I heard Tony
Bennett goes there all the time and I
got to come back and do a show it was
incredible we did it think for the
firefighters just at it we had a we just
had a great [__] time was a wonderful
show and I don't know Staten Island is
really I don't know why it gets all that
[__] it's kind of cool that it does get
a lot of [__] cause it prevents people
from [__] moving there but it's a
really nice green place with a ton of
trees a lot of nice houses just like a
real neighborhood vibe like back in the
day when I was a kid I can't say enough
good things about it so I'm really sold
on really sold on that borough and old
Billy freckles I want to come back to
the st. George - ha you don't take the
ferry over the old ferry taking the
ferry over and I'll [__] do a show
right that went over to [__] top
tomato who got myself a little ball of
[__] French moolah rally
came home everybody was gone Sydney like
a [__] divorce eating little slices
of cheese
you know what kept the cheese moist my
tears sorry anyway I don't know what the
[__] I'm doing here I think I got it I
think I have won advertising read
I literally just hit record I have
nothing to talk about and there's
[__] 19 minutes to go you realize
that I'm one of teachers ever get into
that [__] situation the lessons over
like the oh my god have blown through
all of this [__] now what the [__] am I
gonna talk about you know what they do
then right they just call him the
dumbest kid in the room figuring his
[__] stammer and we'll eat up [__]
a good seven or eight minutes well
didn't you do the assignment he gets
balled out this still called that we get
yelled at by teach I'm sure there's some
Instagram ball down let's see what they
say here balled out new words suggestion
to scold a reprimand usually a child or
a young person by a parent or a guardian
what the [__] is a guardian this is my
new thing like and when I don't know
[__] I'm just [__] looking it up on
the internet cuz god that's where all
the answers are you know guardian of the
galaxy guardians of the galaxy was that
because their real parents couldn't show
up to represent the galaxy am i doing
stand-up from the 80s The Guardian News
report definition yet cont definition of
Guardian protector defender preserver
champion easy Warden guard keeper that
sounds more more in the world I'm
thinking of curator caretaker steward
trustee supervisor all of those words
sound like the person that's Nestle's up
to some [__] old guy you know and
wait for him to die and then all of a
sudden the guy changed his will from the
the steward his caretaker he changed his
will shortly after getting a new
caretaker alright a person who looks
after and is legally responsible for
someone who
unable to manage their own affairs
especially an incompetent or disabled
person or a child whose parents have
died all right I got to look up Guardian
[__] because there's gold-digging
[__] and now you got to have Guardian
[__] Jack the Ripper's victims had to
be [__]
how the hell did I get here how'd I held
it a Carrie Fisher my husband has been
seeing prostitutes what part of the
[__] internet internet internet am I
on why men use prostitutes Quentin
Tarantino produced film post casting
call for [__]
so what Quentin Tarantino produced film
costs casting call for [__] has caused
controversy after a Facebook post
invited [__] to apply why why do women
act like [__] don't exist
I just don't [__] understand it only
they can say who's a [__] and who is it
who's a whoo-whoo
all right Jack the Ripper's victims had
to be [__] no no no it was it was I
write to pay for a prostitute for my
husband there's the winner okay yet did
it at dead christmas comes early with
this article if you are hoping to add to
his repertoire or experience you will
have failed says a woman named and ELISA
Barbary well why did you [__] ask her
all right my husband and I have been
together for six years I married him
when he was 18 and I was 2400 J's is
robbing the cradle I discovered after we
got married that he had sexual
intercourse only with me well you didn't
talk about that before he had sexual
encounters with other women but he
hadn't felt ready for intercourse at
first all he lied he acted like you know
he's was he was a man in the world at
dis but first this wasn't a problem but
now his younger brothers are sexually
active and have had
multiple sexual partners he has started
to feel jealous yeah this marriage is
over
I felt that this jealousy was only going
to grow and I didn't want him to develop
feelings of resentment towards me and
cheat on me geez this woman should get a
[__] award if she's gonna do what I
think she's gonna do I also didn't want
him to think he had missed out and get
into his 30s or 40s and leave me so he
could experience what it feels like to
sleep with other people as his stepdad
did to his mom his mom this must be over
in jolly old England so I took out my
pocketbook
so I booked a holiday to Amsterdam with
the intention of paying for a prostitute
for him I felt this would be a safe
option as it it is a job and no feelings
could develop plus he would know he had
slept with someone other than me I don't
know exactly how we would feel
afterwards but I was willing to take
this risk to save the future of our
marriage okay but now it has happened
and he wasn't happy or fulfilled he said
he felt nothing at all yeah that's that
is usually the feeling and it was very
different and strange unless what
happens when he gets some strange he was
deflated deflated afterwards and now he
won't talk to me about it because he
says it hurts him I'm scared it is upset
him and worried I shouldn't have done
this well you kind of went zero to
[__] 60 well he was kind of driving
10 miles an hour went out a country road
with you but that all of a sudden he got
on the interstate there was somebody who
[__] for a living all right there were
a few things which struck me about your
letter first how few times it said we
even when you talk about your marriage
is a union yeah yeah she's right this
sounds like it was all her fear Oh gives
oh this is what I this is what the
podcast has come to at this point I'm
literally talking about reading somebody
else's [__] letters that someone let
me bring you home a sandwich or
something
no Jesus no I can't eat a sandwich at my
age this late in the day Sun Goes Down
that's it that's no more fun for B Billy
all right all right I mentioned earlier
I went to the Staten Island Yankee
before I did the show at the st.
George's theatre I went out I went to
this sports bar I got a delicious meal
you know and I was with club soda Kenny
and he was like hey Bill you know the
Staten Island Yankees have a whole Gabe
and I was like great let's [__] go so
we went got two tickets behind home
plate watched Staten Island Yankees play
the Connecticut so-and-so's I don't know
who the [__] they were I thought that
was triple-a ball down there it's like
one single lay with something else and I
guess there's three levels of that I
don't know but they were kids we were
watching but they were great and my my
scouting call in that game was the
catcher for Connecticut Cooper Johnson
he was the most impressive threw out a
kid at second base backed up a throw on
first base there was a foul ball going
down the right-field line you know when
they have the bullpens on the field and
the catcher's had that back and the
pitchers had their back to the [__]
play and he just [__] he's like
halfway down the first base line just
yells and like all right we got
ourselves in general that's my pick you
know as cool as you were sitting in next
to us we're like three [__] Scouts
sitting there with a radar gun and I
when I tell you this guy wrote a small
paragraph after every single [__]
pitch I was fascinated by and I was also
thinking like you know that's one of
those things in life
well you just love something so much
that you get a job in it and then all of
a sudden you're working in it and as
much as you still love it a part of your
love for it dies if you got to sit there
sweating your [__] balls off writing
a goddamn soliloquy after every single
[__] pitch you know I'm sure when you
think about getting into the front
office in baseball
you're gonna be eating [__] peanuts
and crackerjacks and smoking cigars
sitting in the dark like that [__]
guy in the natural take might you
banging the fat chick that plays the
organ take old fanbase loves you you win
championship after championship I mean
it's a crackerjack she siding that stud
from the Dominican Republic but next
thing you know you're on the Staten
Island Ferry wearing some slack she
bought nine years ago at Sears Roebuck
you know sitting there with 40 other
people watching a [__] baseball game
can you have a couple of beers no right
can you eat some weed and be trippin
alone now you got to sit there stone
sober with the ballpoint pen in a
notebook writing down paragraphs about
mechanics now maybe I'm superimposing
how I would be feeling I call the front
office at some point be like listen is
it okay if every third game I just when
I got shit-faced after the seventh
inning you know I know what's going on
okay I've seen all the way up to there
middle relief okay and I don't give a
[__] how she's not [__] drunk I am if
they bring in a shutdown closer I'm
gonna notice okay hello this just ed
bill burr fired for the Staten Island
Yankees single a team we're getting
shit-faced before the closer came in
build II have a comment hey I like the
[__] drink why me [__] games my
supposed to go to I called Cooper
Johnson tonight [__] [__] Oh take
me into who the advertising Oh 21
minutes in I've never been so happy to
see 21 here oh by the way oh my god the
big gay thumber
of the NBA oh Jesus do I have some tea
leaves to spill on your yum Yum's kawaii
Leonard however you say it
I just heard he's gonna be spending some
time with LeBron in Los Angeles except
they're gonna be in the same house but
on different in different bedrooms
Leonard just signed with
the [__] the Clippers you know as
much as I'm making fun of the NBA it is
absolutely brilliant what they've done
to only make three teams having a
serious contention be serious contenders
every year and just [__] the rest of the
league you would think that that would
[__] them over but they know
they note attendance has nothing to do
with it it's all about the soap opera
it's all about the stories so they are
now a 12 month 12 months out of the year
it's NBA time the [__] championship
ended a month ago and there's more [__]
there's more [__] on the [__] ESPN
top stories top fives baseball season
[__] baseball top [__] stories are
superstars you know drinking out of
champagne flutes on [__] boats you
know getting into a prayer circle and
all deciding what team they're gonna
pile on next you know what sucks about
that is one of my favorite things I ever
saw was the look Michael Jordan gave the
Detroit Pistons when they walked off the
court when they knew that they were
gonna lose to him and rather than be in
men about it they went off like the
[__] punks I can't say Punk's cuz
they could all kick the [__] out of me
but it's just as far as like you know
that's not the way you do it they just
walked off Isiah shrugging his shoulders
with a stupid smile on his face
the look on Jordans face how he just sat
there and looked at him like you just
see just lost all respect for him you
know I don't know why I love that mall
Pro because I hated the [__] Pistons
but can you imagine if he played today
this is sacrilegious to say this because
I know Jordan wouldn't do it but like a
player of his caliber or somewhere near
his caliber because nobody is would it
just joined the Pistons and then they
would have had a [__] dynasty like
they did out in there and a [__]
wherever the [__] Golden State plays
they played in the state that's gold and
you know who made it the Golden State by
the way huh we all know don't we wasn't
it wasn't the gold rush of the 49ers it
wasn't that at all
[Music]
with their gold pants it wasn't that it
was Robert Plant when he stood at the
rock-and-roll Hyatt right next to the
[__] The Comedy Store
he said I'm a golden God which you know
he never did that was in that book
hammer of the guts
they just said he said it he probably
what he's saying in that photo is I
can't believe how many [__] I'm gonna
[__] out here that's probably what he
said that's what I'm guessing but you
know I think the person just stole the
photo and just said you know oh such a
silly book now looking back having to
read the thing I'm just like at one
point when something bad happened they
said like Jimmy Page walked away
muttering some occult [__] that was just
a bunch of crap but god bless the person
he made some money simply safe everyone
simply saved space simply safe everybody
there are over two million burglaries
reported every year those are just the
ones that are reported and do you know
that a woman is twice as likely to not
report a burglary that's one every 13
seconds wow there's a lot of seconds in
a year huh I think there'd be one every
half a second hang on a second we got to
look this up now how many seconds in a
year quick give me a guess how many
seconds in a year I mean I don't know
what that number is three point one five
for the letter e plus seven I've got a
number how many seconds in a year here
we go gimme come on what do you got what
do you got
alright one day's 24-hour we know that
one total numbers a seconds in 24 hours
3,600 one year is 600 500 thousand 31
million five hundred fifty-seven
thousand six hundred seconds think about
that and what do you do with them and
what's crazy is that only one in five
homes has home security maybe because
most companies really don't make it easy
that's why simply safe is my top choice
yeah oh you know that's all you don't
think there's anything worth stealing in
your house and then on next thing you
know the guy down the street starts
smoking meth and he's got his eye on
your [__] toaster right and he's
coming in with his [__] druggie saliva
through your [__] you're trying to
wash the dishes and he's coming right
through coming right [__] through he's
on bath salts I mean you got to get this
[__] so you I don't like this copy you
got a scare a more simply safe simply
safe protects your whole home every
window room indoor with 24/7 monitoring
for just a fraction of the cost their
police dispatch is up to three and a
half times faster because they use video
verification I don't know what that
means oh yeah oh there's video though
did a bird hit the window no there's a
crackhead crawling through window number
seven here's the video there's no
contract hidden fees or fine print it's
designed to blend right into your home
no wires no drilling it's easy to order
and easy to setup usually in under an
hour
simply safe has won a ton of awards from
CNET to the New York Times wire cutter
prices are always fair and honest
around-the-clock monitoring it's just
$15 a month visit simply safe bird calm
you'll get free shipping and a 60-day
risk-free trial you've got nothing to
lose go now and be sure you go to simply
safe bird comm so they know our show
sent you that simply safe bird comm s IM
p li SI f e capital b you are r dot-com
do t seal it
oh so I'm reading this Ken Stabler book
okay and I remember the year that the
Raiders wanted was actually the year
before I started watching football
religiously I started around the
playoffs playoffs of the 1977 season and
then I watched my first Super Bowl 1978
the Dallas Cowboys first the Denver
Broncos alright and this is the year
before and the New England Patriots had
an incredible team that year when eleven
and three we beat the Miami Dolphins the
pittsburgh steelers and we beat the [__]
out of [__] Oakland Raiders this is
like Ken Stabler's words we beat the
[__] out of him 44 to something then we
met him in the playoffs and the Raiders
went 13 and won that year okay the only
team that beat him was the New England
Patriots so it's kind of funny you know
so they went they went all the way and
[__] well it's not the same as the
Patriots losing to the Giants cause we
lost the Superbowl be the same if the
Giants beat us in the regular season but
we [__] up their perfect season so as
a football fan I wish we didn't you know
just cuz I'm so sick of that stupid [__]
with the the Dolphins you know going
nuts you know cuz they they were
undefeated in a 14 game season with no
24-hour sports networks none of that
[__] [__] it's completely
different time but you do have to
respect it but III didn't know these
[__] out of me anyways so we ended up
playing Oakland in the playoff set year
first round we're playing them again and
it's like third down in 18 and stay low
goes back to pass
he throws a pass it falls incomplete
unlike the three yard line or whatever
you know he threw like a 20 30 yard pass
or some [__] like that so they were
going to be looking at fourth and 18 and
you have to look at this play I'm gonna
post this play for all these [__]
Raider fans who still whine about the
Tuck rule
I mean it's [__] ridiculous ray
Hamilton comes in and is like as as
stable is throwing the ball he like hits
Stabler and his hand was up around his
face but they didn't have that rule back
then like today it would be like
roughing the quarterback just looking at
him
forget about your hand in his face but
that wasn't a rule even stablest says in
the book says christmas came early and
the ref saw a roughing the passer which
brought the ball down now I was under
the impression it brought it down to
like the one-yard line they handed it
off and then that was it but according
to Stabler I cannot find footage of this
part of it because they never show it
but they threw a pass had a run and then
at one point one of the Patriots was
screaming at the official and got in it
was like fourth and one it was going to
be closed and there was a patriot
screaming at the official still probably
bitching about that call and he got an
unsportsmanlike conduct that gave him a
first down and then a play later or two
plays later
the Raiders put it in for the go-ahead
score that was that's how it went down I
didn't realize we lost our composure
like that or whatever but uh it's really
[__] interesting but I can't say
enough about the book too it's a great
[__] book that I'm reading but I had
no idea that we would that good that
year and then I talked then next week
this is what's crazy
the Raiders then played the Pittsburgh
Steelers where the Steelers just owned
the Raiders and Stabler said Franco
Harris and Rocky Bleier their two top
running backs I mean Franco Harris was
like when he retired the only person who
had more yardage than him was was Jim
Brown I believe he was second all-time
when he retired what neither one of them
were playing and Stabler said even if
they were playing I think our defense
the three-four defense that they had was
playing so well they wouldn't have beat
us that day I can't cosign on that I
called up Bart Nick talked to him about
it
that was actually believe it or not that
team that year was the best Steeler team
that's what people say and they could
have actually won three in a row but the
injury bug hit him which cleared the way
that little stupid
[__] roughing the passer call and
then the two injuries to the Steelers
cleared the way and of course the
Raiders being a great team also but just
the amount of [__] luck that you need
you know and I've always said like that
tuck rule is like like the first game
that was just a [__] call the Tuck rule
that was just that was the right call on
a stupid [__] rule because that's a
fumble and you know what's funny that
[__] referee he's now like 93 I want
to interview the guy if I can find him I
would be nice to him if anybody's
listening that knows him
I would love to him I wouldn't I
wouldn't even bring that up I wouldn't
you know someone I wouldn't even bring
up the [__] game I would just want to
hear all his stories about you know
officiating games with Walter Payton and
all of these amazing dick butkus and all
like they say this whole time when he
played was wasn't official I should say
but he even said that that was a fumble
he goes out that's a fumble but not
according to the rule it isn't and the
whole point of the rule was to avoid
confusion about what was a fumble and
what wasn't but that one little lucky
thing that happened to us you know
Christmas came again Kent Stabler I
wonder what he thought when he watched
that game he probably laughed like Iowa
ago they finally got us back he just
seems like the coolest [__] dude ever
and people listen to podcast know that I
[__] I love the south and I love
Alabama you know I don't like a lot of
[__] obviously all the stuff about like
the racism and the Klan and all that but
I've traveled enough to sit there and I
understand like that that that [__]
where they act like it's just down there
you know is in and in Boston is so is
[__] ridiculous so anyways I like it
down there I like the pace down there
it's a beautiful [__] state and it's
fun to read about someone that really
enjoys it down there and he was talking
about how during the offseason he'd go
down and he had a place right down on
the shores of the Gulf of Mexico you
know they call that the redneck Riviera
there's a few places that they call
redneck Riviera but that was one you
know that they
and I thought he bought this [__]
zillion dollar boat like big-ass boat
with whatever money he was making back
then so it was tens of thousands of
dollars which was a ton of [__] money
back then and he was talking about being
on there and him and his buddy split in
a bottle of Johnnie Walker red not even
black definitely not blue if they even
had blue I don't know when blue came out
but I didn't he said that or an ice cold
Budweiser and I was like this guy I
would have loved to a [__] hung out
with that guy because I got a mint like
I've tried you know fancy liquor and and
fancy beers and all that but there's
just certain ones
it's like child sense memory even when
you eat McDonald's you know what you
know it's not good for you you know
you're gonna feel like [__] but when you
smell it in you're eating it it takes
you back to when your parents took there
when you took you there when you were a
kid you didn't have a care in the world
there's like alcohol like that for me
and it's Michelob light the first thing
I ever got a buzz off of and then Miller
High Life to me always reminds me of
drinking with Joe bartnik and whenever
we're drinking them we're always having
the best [__] time and uh and then
any sort of like I don't know whiskey's
and [__] like that just reminds me of RZ
law at bartnik the whole [__] all
those [__] knuckleheads that I hang
out with it's a great book I highly
recommend it and speaking of books you
can pre-order hard-to-handle
that's the book that Steve Gorman of the
Black Crowes wrote and I got to tell you
if you are not a fan of the Black Crowes
you're not a fan of music if you're not
a fan of reading
you're still gonna love this book that's
how I'm [__] amazing this book is it's
like just holds nothing back you know I
was reading the [__] I'm just like I
can't imagine him Tim telling his wife
any more than he's telling me he just
[__] let it fly and if [__] was going
good with the band he talked about how
awesome it was if it was going like [__]
he just said went like [__] and this guy
was a [__] [__] and I wanted to
kill kill him
phenomenal books called hard-to-handle I
tweeted out the link definitely give it
a it's it's
yeah it's it's a great [__] read so
look at me with all the summertime reads
here hard to handle by Steve Gorman I'm
reading the Ken Stabler book I forget
the name of the book it's got the the
Raider helmet and he's got ice in there
with like a Budweiser Astros and
something else he's using it as like a
cooler and Joe Barton it got me the book
because he's a class [__] act and
that's it that's it for the podcast I
hope you guys are having a great week
you have a wonderful weekend you [__]
thank you to everybody that came out to
the st. George Theatre in Staten Island
I will definitely be back I am beyond
sold on Staten Island I love it it's
definitely gonna be a tour stop next
year when I get this new hour together
if not sooner man I just it just yet you
know some of those venues just have the
magic and that one definitely did so I
will definitely be back all right that's
the podcast enjoy the music a little
musical interlude here and then we'll
have another half an hour a little bonus
episode of greatest hits I should say
over Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the Monday morning podcast for
Monday July 11th 2011 see that look at
me two 11s and I and I blew right
through it no problems whatsoever I
think this is gonna be a good podcast
all right so here we are it's another
Monday it's another Monday do you know
where your dreams are I am going out of
my [__] mind this week people as
opposed to the other weeks when I'm so
relaxed and chilled and realizing what's
important in life this week believe it
or not I'm a little off the Zen path if
you can believe it I've been in my
[__] up.i all goddamn day and I
realized today after being in my
apartment the entire [__] day coz my
girl had the car all right
you know how I'm living my life
debt-free I could go out and get another
one
you know you think I'm not a big shot
you think I couldn't go out there and go
get myself a [__] mercury monarch put
some rims on that [__] you think I
can't live like that be I choose not to
okay cuz it's obnoxious
I don't flaunt my ability to get
Mercury's answer to the Ford Granada
actually I would go out on a limb and
say the mercury was a little bit better
because as far as the lineage goes the
mercury back in the day anyways was was
a for a man was making a little more
money wanted to stick with the Lincoln
Ford product right did I lose all the
legs on that one
did I
well that's good anyway so I've been in
this [__] apartment all [__] day
and uh I don't know I just realized I
not only I don't the [__] I'm talking
you know what I could never work on a
submarine you ever see those things
about those sailors sailors who they
joined the Navy right a lot of people
don't know like people who join the Navy
they were already sailors you already
have to be a sailor before you go into
the Navy I don't know if you guys knew
that you got to show up okay you already
have to have you a little outfit on with
a little hat you know it got come in
there dressed like Popeye have won at
least one anchor tattoo and then you got
to do a little dance with a mop and if
you do it
you move on to the next round and on the
next round what do you got to do you got
to do something else something with a
pipe I can't remember you start smoking
a pipe and I need a can of spinach and
then you're in that's how it works I
know a lot of you thinking like Bill you
know technically was still at war you
know why are you making front of that
branch of the military and I'll tell you
why because that's the safest one to be
in I said this before and I'll say it
again a long time ago I said it on the
uninformed show with Joe DeRosa the teen
idol sensation from the Opie and Anthony
program I said it a long [__] time ago
there has not been any great naval
battle footage since World War two
all right so basically if you want to
have you know the ability later on in
your life when you're an old man and
you're acting like a total douche and
people are calling on it calling you on
it you and you want to be able to be
like if you want to be able to yell that
and not have to worry about your safety
you joined the Navy I mean that's the
way to go if you don't believe me I am
other I have a lot of listeners I
believe in the Army in the Marines and
the Air Force that would gladly send me
emails to tell me to agree with me that
that is that's the coward's way out
[Laughter]
I'm just [__] with you all right
before you [__] call FoxNews and they
give you you know only those people on
TV with jowls people always question
people's patriotism I always seem to
have javis if you notice that um anyways
yeah I've been in this [__] apartment
all goddamn day long and I'm going
absolutely nuts and I want to go out
tonight okay I want to feel the wind in
what's left of my hair I'm gonna hang my
head out the window like [__] Ace
Ventura and I'm gonna drive my quiet
hybrid down the street okay this is the
kind of life I live people you know you
too could be in show business and live
this sort of rock style lifestyle rock
star life they say rock style lifestyle
you know what Bill why do you even
bother you know what [__] you why do you
even listen why is it always on me this
is what I did this week people I came
home and I don't know what the [__] I
was supposed to do but I walked into my
bathroom and I saw that I had a leaky
faucet and immediately I got excited
because I was like oh my god I was like
oh my god there is a problem all right
there's a problem and I know how to fix
it I know how to fix that [__]
all I do is I unscrew that little thing
that the faucet handle pops right off
and then right underneath it's that
thing that looks like a [__] spy plug
right pull that thing out this the
little washer you take it out you stick
a new one in BAM and you reverse the
process I've done it I've done it like
five times since I've been in this
apartment and by five I probably mean to
but we're gonna say five reality was
probably two but I feel like I've done
it like five times
so I walk in there bring in my little
toolbox like a I bring it in that little
red one little fire engine red toolbox
and I come walking in you know looking
like the puppet that I look like and I
open it up right where have my Allen
wrenches unscrew that
little [__] thing and Here I am took
the screw out I did everything right I
put the towel right up down in the sink
right over the the drain mouth so I
wouldn't lose it down there
I put the screw white where oh I knew it
was gonna be right in the little area
where I brush my teeth everything's
going well so far
all systems go so I unscrew the [__]
thing right everything's good and I go
to take the handle off lo and behold it
won't come off
seems a little fussy so I start jiggling
it a little bit I start tugging at it I
go wait a minute bill wait a minute
let's not break anything and turn this
easy repair into something bigger so
what do I do I go onto YouTube already
getting embarrassed go and I already
know how to fix this [__] thing I was
gonna show off that I know how to do
this so my girl could be like oh my god
you're so you're funny and you're handy
right and it would just fill up my ego
so I go on the [__] YouTube how to
fix a leaky faucet and every
[__] on there they're unscrewing
a little screw the handle pops right off
and they're on to the job so I'm like
son of a [__] maybe there's some sort
of gunk in there so I start tugging it a
little [__] harder and in the back of
my head it keeps going don't do this
it's gonna break don't do this I start
looking at it going did I did I take a
wrench out it was there something else I
had to [__] unscrew it I just can't
figure it out and finally what happens I
lose my temper and I go I'm yanking this
[__] off right what happens snap
the goddamn handle snap the [__]
thing off like halfway down part of the
threads are in there it's this old
vintage [__] faucet handle so I had
this simple goddamn job oh halfway
through I called my [__] dad to have
to figure out how to do it and I was
already pissed which is funny isn't that
funny when you call somebody at midway
through a job you know he's just hanging
out he's just like hello Mike yeah it's
bill I'm trying to fix the [__]
faucet he's just like gzz easy you know
you just hit the ground running scream
Nana oh you know what you want to do
their bill is yeah you want to you want
to unscrew and I'm like I [__] did
that already I already did that I tried
to do it he go Ellen jiggle it I juggled
it you know and I yelled at him so much
he started getting mad he's like well
[__] call a plumber I'm like I'm not
gonna [__] call a plumber of a
goddamn linkies [__] faucet he's like
well I don't want to tell you I said
fine I'll call you later he goes all
right goodbye you know so that was the
upside of it I got a little father-son
quality time quality time in there so
what do I do I say [__] this I got I got
a goddamn screwdriver I'm trying to for
that the whole time I'm going what step
that I miss what did I do it I just push
this up here sorry about that I'm like
what step that I just [__] miss so as
you know as always my temper does me in
and what do I do I [__] yank this
thing off it snaps off and now I still
have a leaky faucet and I have half a
goddamn handle so of course you know the
male ego I can't say anything to my girl
right
I just [__] walk out head down two
feet I look you know I look like I look
like [__] Peyton Manning in the third
quarter of a playoff game I got that
Peyton face you know I undid my chin
strap and I'm already looking for
somebody to throw under the bus to blame
it on right I start blaming my landlord
because he likes everything I'll [__]
old rather than just you know putting
the blame on my shoulders and being a
[__] leader so like I said I walk out
of there that's the only thing I was
missing was a Peyton Manning jersey as I
walk out my stupid sweaty forehead and I
just walk out and I wait for Nia to
discover it right and she comes in and
she knows I've been flipping out she
heard me yell at my dad about a washer
you know
stupid [__] another three minutes of
my life I'll never get back because of
my dumbass temper and she goes in and
immediately comes out she's like what
happened to the think was what are you
like are you halfway through the job now
it's done
sweetie still leaks and now there's half
a handle anything else you need me to go
take care of here I am the man about the
house so um anyway so I've gone on I've
gone on eBay have gone everywhere I'm
trying to find it's not a really unique
faucet handle it's just an older one and
out of respect for the guy who owns this
place I want to get a new one
does anybody any podcast listener and my
Los Angeles Angeles area know where I
can find do they have old is Aris is
there a Fred Sanford house out here that
just will have a bunch of old faucet
handles that's what I need to know I
have pictures of my damaged faucet
handle up on the the mm podcast.com the
official fan page of the Monday morning
podcast and once again it's WWE mm
podcast com people seem to be having
problems sometimes finding it and
anybody out there that knows how to
[__] do it if you can look at it and
tell me where I went wrong I even took a
picture of the goddamn screw where I
unscrewed it what else would be holding
it in I don't understand it
obviously you don't understand it bill
you [__] broke it so I'm embarrassed
I'm embarrassed that's one of the first
things I learned how to do when plumbing
and I was beyond excited I probably
talked about it three years ago on the
podcast for those of you searching in
the archives I don't know what happened
this is lot but what kills me about that
is that is a microcosm of my life
it's like there's an obstacle I learn
how to defeat it and then I walk away
and I completely forget everything that
I've learned and then [__] six months
later I'm in the same situation I lose
my temper and the thing blows up in my
face and you know I'm 43 years old so
who's kidding who wouldn't you say I'm
beyond the halfway point in my life you
got to think that I mean 86 years you
know that's long enough for a curse
everybody I think I'm gonna make it into
my 90s
and I want to hear everybody talking
about my temper and how it's causing
high blood pressure go [__] yourself I
go for hikes that's how I even it off
that's how he level it off
speaking of curses by the way I saw
something I'm submitting jokes to an
award show the ESPYs trying to get some
jokes on there and so I've been reading
all this sports stuff you know just
everything every [__] article like it
I could come up with and evidently
somebody on ESPN was announcing the
Cleveland Indians Yankees game on a
Saturday night and they did the usual
montage of Cleveland misery sports which
not even being a Cleveland fan I could
pretty much say that what they are it's
the Michael Jordan shot I don't know who
it's over some [__] white guy of
course and he jumps up and he's doing
the fist pump it's the John Elway Drive
it's the fumble was an earnest Byner I
don't know who the [__] it was fumble
and was the last time the Indians wanted
1948 is that what it is that's pretty
much it in a microcosm and then I guess
they added LeBron James leaving so all
these Cleveland fans not a you know
started giving this ESPN guy [__] for
trash and Cleveland and saying that ESPN
has a bias against Cleveland and that
it's lazy journalism and all this type
of [__] and you know bla bla bla bla bla
and I got to tell you there's only one
way you're gonna stop it all right this
is coming from a [__] Boston fan
where I had to watch that goddamn
Buckner [__] replay a zillion goddamn
times I went to a Tampa Bay Devil Rays
game and they chanted 1918 at me they
did it at the Philly Stadium all that
type of [__] it was just you know the
Bucky Dent home run the whole goddamn
yeah basically you got to win a
championship or they're never gonna stop
showing it and and I hate to tell you
what you already know but you guys
considering the White Sox you know you'd
think it was Chicago after Boston
finally won something you know you would
think that maybe
would be Chicago but they I was thinking
they got the Bulls they have the Bears
they got the White Sox and then the
Blackhawks just wanted so it's kind of
you guys you know this is off the top of
my head I think the last championship
you won was 64 you weren't an NFL title
so you gotta expect to get some [__] I
feel for you and you know remember when
I said that I was gonna uh I retired as
a sports fan I retired like Jay Z as a
sports fan after the Bruins won the
Stanley Cup cuz I've seen all four in my
lifetime and and within the last seven
years so I'm done it's never gonna get
any better I'm walking away from the
blackjack table I'm up I'm going back to
my room I might order a hooker you know
get a little [__] I can't say that you
know whatever it's my Catholic
upbringing even though I still don't
believe in the [__] I always stopped
short on a lot of the sex jokes you know
oh jeez yeah walked away so I am now a
fan of of cities that need a
championship and I root for your [__]
teams that's what I'm doing from here on
out the rest of it I don't give a [__]
you know I unless it's like New York
fans he just never can be sympathetic to
New York fans because they just feel
they just feel that they're successful
just because they don't even live in New
York City they just live near it and
then includes New Jersey and they listen
to that stupid song if I can get
anywhere and they think really let me
ask you this why don't you look in the
mirror and see your man tits pushing
through your New York Jets jersey let me
ask you a question are you really making
it there you know I don't think you
could make it in [__] Idaho well why
is it so hard to make it in New York you
got [__] everything there it's
[__] easy living go live in Idaho you
and your friends are just sitting there
trying to make a pipe bomb out of a
[__] potato or whatever the hell it
is they do out there you you want to go
live out there
New Yorker ya bunch of [__] so actually
I have a new favorite baseball team
alright so I'm always gonna root for the
Red Sox if they're in the playoffs go
[__] yourself I have to have that
loyalty but I'm actually paying more
attention to the Pittsburgh Pirates
because they were that was my favorite
team when I was a kid you know we member
that [__] 1979 you remember that I
[__] love that team and you know I
was still [__] devastated after the
Bucky Dent home run that was a year
later I was a nice kick in the [__]
ten-year-old seeds welcome to being a
Boston sports fan you know the Bucky
Dent home run fortunately I was too
young to remember that horseshit
roughing the passer call we played the
Oakland Raiders which is why I always
laugh when I hear Raider fans crying
about the Tuck rule that was payback was
payback just like when we rescued France
in [__] World War two we weren't
doing him a favor that was payback when
they [__] saved our asses from the
goddamn cozy smug [__] over there in
England anyway so you guys wanna hear
something [__] hilarious this is this
is a new topic that I want to introduce
onto the podcast this is something that
I noticed you ever just been sitting at
home watching something by yourself okay
and you're watching something that isn't
supposed to be funny and inadvertently
it's [__] hilarious
and you just wish you could share it
with other people well with today's
technology people you can why is the bed
sliding away from the [__] wall here
hang on a second this is my bed I have
no headboard on my bed do you understand
that people this is how you live a
debt-free lifestyle okay
I have [__] damn pelo jammed pillow I
can never say that word I say PLL oh I
have white sheets that are gray you know
by the way overrated white socks three
washes
[__] gray I don't give a [__] how
much bleach you pour in there they don't
you open the goddamn dryer door it looks
like a [__] overcast day and just
depresses the [__] out of you alright
underrated black socks alright like
Angus Young and [__] Michael Jordan
alright so here we go see sitting alone
is the new topic you sitting alone
minding your own [__] business you're
watching something that's not supposed
to be funny and then out of nowhere they
just say something [__] hilarious and
you laugh your ass off me like god
dammit I wish there was other people
here so they could have enjoyed that too
we could add a nice laugh well with
today's technology people you can
especially if you buy an olympus LS ten
like i have are they up to the LS eleven
yet how about you [__] [__]
advertised on this podcast huh there's
my sales pitch
anyways III noticed this I remember
bringing this up a long time ago I was
watching one of those murder shows I
always watched the murder shows the
trials the [__] on serial killers the
jails i watch all that [__] and I was
watching one one time and it was about
these two serial killers and that
actually joined forces like Batman and
Robin and one of them had already
committed murders and then he moved to
another city and that's where he meets
the other serial killer and that Bill
Kurtis guy or something is doing the
narration and when he describes the one
serial killer meeting his new friend
they go he then moved on to wherever and
he goes there he met a sometimes
transvestite no a there he there he met
yeah sometimes transvestite and
pyromaniac I still remember where I was
I butchered the line I still remember
where I was when I [__] heard that I
was actually working the improv in Tempe
Arizona and I was sitting in the hotel
bed after doing two tremendous shows of
course not to Pat myself on the back I
always have a good time out there right
and then I was watching it and Bill
Curtis I and I turned on the TV and I
caught like two minutes before and
that's when Bill Curtis just went there
he met a sometimes transvestite and pie
maniac and I bursted out laughing by
myself and I was like god damn it I wish
someone else could have enjoyed that so
with that setup people here's the one
that I saw today I was watching this
[__] on not Christ I just closed the
[__] window what the hell's wrong
with me I was watching this show called
behind Mansion walls and it was all
about these rich guys it was basically
about rich guys who were divorcing women
and they didn't want to give him any
money
and then they would kill him and then
because they had so much money it was
kind of this 50/50 as to whether they
got away with it or not which was you
know added to the tension of watching it
but was also really [__] disturbing
because these guys could you know this
one guy paid thirteen million dollars to
his lawyer and of course the guy gets
him off you got that kind of money you
can buy your way out of a problem just
like the [__] New York Yankees
they're never gonna suck again I don't
give a [__] how many Carl Pavano knows
they sign they got enough money to walk
away from it and sadly so to the Red Sox
I know we're part of the problem but
whatever so I'm watching the show behind
Mansion walls and the guy you know we're
13 million dollars you know whatever he
pays his lawyer thirteen million dollars
and he [__] what the hell's this
goddamn clip I don't know whatever so
it's part of their defense thing where
the hell is it are you [__] me
why do I do this upset well here it is
this this is something this this was a
person describing his ex-wife some other
rich person within the town that
believed the rich guy was innocent and
this is I don't know where this is a
show about some poor woman who lost her
life because this [__] [__] you
know you going through a divorce dude
like he you know why don't you spend
thirteen million on a divorce lawyer I'm
sure you'll be able to keep most of your
goddamn money you [__] [__] you know
I mean God knows you know the history of
this podcast that I am all about you
know I'm always defending the guys how
bad guys get [__] over in
and in [__] divorces Jesus Christ
could I me and ur anymore through this
why don't I just play the goddamn clip
so this this lady his next-door neighbor
is talking about the some girl who's
gonna testify against this guy oh paid
his lawyer 13 million dollars and this
is a really serious show and I'm on the
edge of my seat go and [__] is this guy
gonna get away with this [__] and this
is what the lady said here it is that's
the way they edited it ah Jesus I'm
trying to shut this [__] thing off
that's what she said
they thought that she was a [__] and
then they cut to the [__] lady who
was just called a [__] in trial going
that is not true and I [__] burst it
out laughing and I was like god dammit I
want to share that with some people and
you know it's funny halfway through that
I started losing confidence of whether
it's even funny cuz they did such a bad
job setting it up
why not [__] did it I'm the worst I took
the wrong one that's why that's why what
is that and the worst you know you know
what you know I've had just about enough
of my [__] unprofessional I got to
get somebody in here to help me out with
this [__] you know it's better this
podcast would be if I actually had
somebody sitting here and I just had him
playing the goddamn clip I got to start
[__] doing that [__] I'm really doing
this is not me asking for you guys to
send me emails I already have somebody
that I'm gonna use okay I don't want
people who live in New Hampshire but I
could fly out there if you paid for the
ticket I'm not into that
I appreciate appreciate the help alright
so I tried something new this week I
actually printed out some stuff rather
than so I wouldn't have to text my
weaith not text my way through this sit
here and uh not Jesus Christ I can't
even multitask here I'm trying to
explain what I'm doing as I'm setting
this [__] thing up why don't I just
get this podcast has just gone off the
goddamn rails this overhead light is
making me
what like this fat [__] I just saw in
that man vs. food he's actually
challenging other fatties to go out
there and they went to Boston and I
gotta tell you men I hate to say this
being from Boston but there are some
ugly sons of [__] from Boston it's
just if there's no happy medium
they're either good looking or [__]
this dude he look like a pelican he had
this giant [__] chin I just it was oh
god the skanks in the background
cheering him on as he's eating it was a
six pound burger they were trying to eat
and you know Ozzy who suck at math
that's like twenty four quarter pounders
with cheese
- the bun I guess the bun was jagneaux
know they they they had a bunch of
little patty so was it with if you just
ate one bun and then you ate 24 of those
[__] patties and these fatties are
[__] chomping their way through it so
anyways they don't even why the [__] it
went into that yeah but why don't you
make fun of fat people once again all
right
let's plow ahead here somebody actually
sent me this this link here it said Bill
you may have more influence than you
realize now I realize that I didn't have
an influence on this but this makes me
happy it says major grocery grocer
getting rid of self checkout lanes all
those years you guys seen my specials
I've been going off on those things
saying how you're basically you're just
working for free and putting a fellow
American out of business
out of work I should say it says one of
the nation's major grocery store chains
is eliminating self checkout lanes in an
effort to encourage more human contact
with its customers isn't it hilarious
when a corporation tries to lie how they
try and spin it I'm gonna go with eat
they didn't work I'm gonna go with the
reason why they're doing it is because
people were stealing too much food or
the average human being was too [__]
stupid to figure out how to do it no
matter how much they explain to it
explained it to him so rather than just
admitting defeat they try to spit it in
this positive way
rather than just coming out yeah you
know we tried to explain it to them but
you know the amount of mouth breathers
out there is just absolutely it's
catastrophic and it didn't make it
cost-effective we just realized that we
would be explaining these things until
the end of time or they would come out
and just be like we've ascertained of
the 24,000 carton of eggs that were on
the shelf only 18,000 973 were paid for
so we're gonna go back to the human way
of doing these things if there's any
questions you can go [__] yourself
because I'm walking away from the podium
um so this is basically how they spin it
one of the nation's major major grocery
store chains is eliminating self
checkout lanes in an effort to encourage
more human contact with its customers
here comes Santa Claus here comes Santa
Claus Albertsons which operates 217
stores in seven western and southern
states will eliminate all self checkout
lanes in the hundred stores that have
them and will replace replace them with
standard or Express Lanes a spokeswoman
said here comes some more [__] from
the Albertsons people we just want the
opportunity to talk to customers more
that's the driving motivation no it
isn't no it isn't you lying [__]
talking head you know what I think it is
I bet it was when you went through there
please you guys by the way present your
theories I bet when you went through
there that people weren't using their
little savvy save cards they weren't
used in something they weren't getting
enough information it's one of those
three you know we just wanted the
opportunity to talk to the customers
more they want to [__] worm their way
in there this is what you do so just go
to that place use their thing and don't
talk to the person behind the counter or
will talk to them but stop short of
giving them any sort of personal
information we have your phone number no
no you can't they usually just say can
we have a phone number so just give them
one a nine one six four five two one two
three four go [__] yourself
privately-held abre Albertsons are
rates in Arizona Colorado Florida
Louisiana New Mexico Texas in Utah the
move does not effect stores operated by
the grocery giant Super Value which
operates more than 450 Albertsons you
[__]
including Southern California goddamnit
well you know what these are privately
owned ones so maybe that this could
actually be a good thing maybe that's
why they did maybe they actually wanted
more human contact you know it would
help if I actually read these halfway
through so let me change my bitching to
see yeah see the big corporate guys they
don't give a [__] they're still trying
to [__] make you work for free but
these nice privately owned ones ok
douche bag of the week me for not
reading that whole [__] thing alright
well that's a good thing though that's a
good thing I like it
I like that there they're going back to
human context so they go maybe some
people can get some goddamn jobs out
there
all right this podcast is completely off
the rails here let's uh let's plow ahead
here and let's go with some some advice
for the week a bill I've been talking to
this chick who I met on this random
chatting site for about three months now
we talk almost all the time over Instant
Messenger she told me that she lives in
New York but she's originally from here
Los Angeles
I never video or voice chatted with her
but she sent me pictures of what she
looked like
oh Jesus the thing that bothers me is
every time I bring up the subject of
video chatting or voice chatting with
her she gets real pissy and changes the
subject on a side note mostly the reason
I want a video chat with her or a voice
chat with her is because I'm still on
the fence on whether or not it's a dude
what but the thing that makes me doubt
that it is what okay on the side note
mostly the I'm on the fence and whether
or not it's a do but the thing that
makes me doubt that is that she always
texts me in the morning to wake up and
chat with her on I am people please
write in complete sentences
well about two weeks ago she agreed to
video chat but the thing is she gets
home around 3:00 or 4:00 a.m. her time
which is 12:00 or 1:00 here that day I
was exhausted from work so I fell asleep
the thing I found odd was that she
didn't even text me when she got home
and she always does not saying I was I
forced her to text me because I'm not
some clingy [__] when I asked her why
she didn't text me she said because she
didn't want to wake me but she always
seems to text me and wakes me with the
text saying wake up or 1 or 2 at 1 or 2
a.m. so I let that go the next week she
says that she wants to voice chat with
me then five minutes later she says she
has to go and that will voice chat when
she gets home which is around 12 a.m.
here I stayed up and not once did she
sign on or on so I called it quits
around 3 a.m. Jesus Christ dude
why don't you just watch some porn jerk
off and go to bed and [__] forget
this this goddamn what's behind door
number 4 why are you doing this to
yourself I'm not even done with this and
I already have a solution watch porn and
jerk off and go talk to people in a bar
anyways let's let's get through this
then when I asked her what happened and
if she wanted to chat she avoided the
question and got pissed off so I finally
said [__] this I'm done and I blew her
off do you think I should let this go
and stop talking to this chick I think I
already answered this or do you think
I'm just blowing this out of proportion
one last thing you should know is that
me and this person talked for hours at a
time and I'm really not sorry for this
long message because I'm paying to go
see you in Irvine during your Thursday
show so there you go hope you get back
to me thanks uh yeah dude there's like
there was already like three major red
flags in here first of all you're
talking about distance it seems she
lives in New York you live in LA so
that's not gonna [__] work out you
got to stay up till all hours of the
goddamn night waiting to talk to her so
that's not gonna work out and then she
doesn't want to do the video chat so
most likely the photo she sent you
was probably when she looked her best is
what I'm guessing and then you threw in
there it might be a dude so I really
don't think you need my advice here
alright so I don't think you need a
long-distance relationship with some fat
transvestite there you go there you are
sir ah you dodged a bullet in nine years
of therapy all right bill I'm a big fan
of the podcast all right here we go my
boyfriend and I have been dating
exclusively for about eight months now
and things are getting are pretty great
there's just one little hiccup that I
was hoping you could help with a few
months back I told my boyfriend that
when we were first started dating I also
went on a date with another guy it was
just a concert and a little goodnight
kissing and then we went our separate
ways at the time I was recently single
and I was exploring my options but
didn't feel much of a connection with
the second guy and he never really
showed much of an interest back so there
wasn't much contact after the date
there wasn't much contact after a date
okay you've left that open-ended all
right we work at the same company
but entirely different offices so we do
run into each other from time to time
and have casual hallway chitchat oh my
god I swear to god women if you were a
little bit bigger you'd be the greatest
major-league [__] catcher's of all
time the way you can frame your [__]
[__] and make it look better than it
really is
that was clearly a ball outside and you
just framed that into a nice little
strike there didn't you there wasn't
much contact after the date
there wasn't much interest we had just
started dating we work at the same
company but it's different offices we do
run into each other time to time for
just a little chit chat gee oh Jesus all
right here we go I told my boyfriend
about this and he forgave me and said he
understood and all was well until
recently guy number two number two uh
how pathetic help with the poetic is
that the piece of [__] number two asked
me out again about two months ago and I
politely declined and said I was seeing
someone else now
he backed off and that was the end of
that in an effort to be open and honest
I know I would have normally kept this
to myself I told my boyfriend about it
alright as always I haven't read this
whole thing but why would you do that
okay you know if you truly don't have
feelings for that [__] guy who gives
a [__] don't say anything okay you think
your boyfriend it hasn't gone out and
the local [__] at the bar who just got
her tits done and wanted to show him to
everybody like she got her nails did
right didn't pull her titty out you know
he doesn't need to tell you that cuz he
wants to keep going down there drinking
with his friends he doesn't give a [__]
if some [__] you know you can keep to
yourself so anyways she goes I told my
boyfriend about it now he keeps asking
me to retell the date story and flat-out
tells me he thinks I'm lying
he thinks something more happened and he
said from a man's perspective there is
just no way this guy goes on a date with
me gets a kiss and then leaves me alone
there's something you're not telling me
he says I've told my boyfriend that
there just wasn't a connection
conversation was a little awkward and
forced the kiss wasn't great etc etc but
he's still very suspicious I'm wondering
if there is anything I can say to put
his mind at ease no no you [__] up you
[__] up by telling him that look at
all the details how openly you
open-ended you've left his stuff where
it's like you know I went on a date when
we first started seeing each other you
know because we weren't official and
then you say there wasn't much contact
after the date so that means there was
some contact I guess you're saying the
contact was that you work at the same
company but it's different offices so
you run into each other from time to
time so it's casual hallway chitchat is
that what it is this is kind of vague so
anyways he said she says I'm tempted to
show him my own old phone bills to prove
how many texts were sent back and forth
to make him feel like an [__] I think
that's
good move I shouldn't make them like
what you should do is to clear your own
name he's not the [__] in this you
are or you naive because you you first
of all you told them that you went on
another date while you guys are first
seeing each other he forgave you for all
that [__] even though you made out with
this guy at work he looks the other
[__] way and then you come home with
this this [__] like what like what did
you think that you were gonna what what
did you think it was gonna do other than
make him feel insecure and jealous and I
know there's probably a lot of ladies
listening right now I'm bi well that's
the thing see guys are so [__]
insecure you can't even be honest shut
up so are you okay
if you [__] just started dating some
dude and he gets all honest he goes yeah
I also you know went on a date with some
chick from work we made out but it's
kind of awkward and whatever I run into
her from time to time right and then you
you say fine no biggie and then a few
months since a relationship he brings up
that she comes back into the picture and
starts [__] you know comes back in
the picture and asked if you know if
he'd like to go on a drink with her and
have a drink with her you know on a
drink with her go out and have a date
with her you know know go out on a date
or have a drink with her god damn it I'm
[__] you'd have a problem with that
right
so anyways she said I guess I'm mostly
frustrated because he's accusing me of
lying and this about this innocent event
I should just play along answer his
question till he drops it or should I
just play along I've told him that the
constant questioning bothers me and I
don't like being accused of lying but I
see it eating at him from time to time
so I feel like it's an issue we'll keep
coming up until something changes do you
think over time he'll just let it go and
eventually believe me what should I do
all right I I just okay first and
foremost wait I'm gonna open the [__]
window because I don't give a [__] if
you guys can hear the traffic it's too
goddamn hot hey slow down there's kids
out here
anyways in the future if some guy makes
advances at you and you don't give a
[__] you honestly don't give a [__]
don't bring it up to your boyfriend
because all you're doing is just gonna
make him jealous and you're gonna make
him feel insecure that there's guys out
he knows that there's guys out there
trying to [__] his girlfriend he doesn't
need to hear about it
why would you do that to him alright and
at this point you know I would just say
that what you've been telling me that if
you truly believe this all right
because part of me is thinking that you
did this to make him feel jealous so you
could feel [__] attractive and then he
flipped out and now it's got a little
out of your control here so now you want
to hear you know you're looking for some
sort of sympathy from somebody else part
of me is thinking that but you actually
I don't know if something about you kind
of seemed like a nice person so I'm
gonna believe you here so I would
actually get your phone bills and show
it to him alright and just say I'm
guilty of being too [__] honest I'm
sorry
and I think I think it'll be alright it
might be alright you know I don't know I
have no [__] idea I just don't know
why women I don't know why they do [__]
like that they seem to do that ah Jesus
Christ bill
why do you lump all women into
everything you're ever gonna get past
your [__] issues alright let's move
on to the next one you know I'm really
just having enough with the whole me
always trash in women it's getting tired
I'm sick of doing it so to balance out
the podcast you know what we're gonna do
I'm gonna bring in a special guest I'm
gonna bring in a [__] the wonderful
Nia as always putting up with me and my
[__] mm-hmm and [__] you okay you
can't even go won't even be nice for
like this come in it because I'm sitting
there I'm trying to open up yeah that I
know that I'm a jerk
yeah and then you have to like I hate
well I hate that I hate I hate when
someone goes like when they're actually
going like listen I
wrong I shouldn't have done X Y & Z now
husband uh-huh right it just makes you
want to do it again that just means that
I'm listening please don't do this I'm
trying not that I'm trying to get over
my issues that I have with women and
what you're doing is you're feeding
right into a totally white white really
it doesn't take much do I weigh that's
true but do I really have to listen back
to the way you win uh-huh how you just
did that at least that's the way I heard
it least that's alright I brought you in
here because yeah I'm done great you
know what just to make you feel better
I'm getting sick of me my tired [__]
views there we go all right here we go
now this is the advice the advice okay
and this is from a woman here and I
really need your advice on this one cuz
I just some some woman just wrote in and
I actually I'm feeling bad already cuz I
think she was kind of nice and I
immediately just started thrashing her
which really had nothing to do with her
really had to do with me and the issues
that I have is this this letter or
something that was the previous one
okay we're listening to what I said a
few seconds ago did you apologize huh
did you apologize did you admit that you
felt that maybe it had more to do with
your issues and what she wrote yeah okay
that was a very nice segue to coming in
here so are you happy now yeah I do the
right thing yeah that's great okay all
right here we go so here's this lady
this lady writes in here a bit of advice
here I need a bit of advice here I feel
guilty is I feel as though I am the
friend Jesus let me start over I feel
it's the hope I'm really having a rough
time yeah baby
I really have a rough time here I feel
as though I am the friend that breaks up
romance I feel guilty that I am the one
who caused problems to the relationships
of my guys friends I'm not sure what it
is but I think my friends talk to me
more than they talk to their women and
jealousy develops oh my god
let me finish purely factual I know I
was better-looking than them
wait but I wouldn't say I'm Megan Fox
either I have been compared to Katy
Perry
I guess she's pretty too but whatever
[__] Syrian oh she really wrote that
and I butchered it the way I read it oh
my god now I'm in a situation that I
don't know what to do with two of my
friends guys seem to be flirting with me
all the time sayings things that I see
as a guy would only say to his
girlfriend I'm not really a flirty
person I'm a good listener
but talk a lot so conversations are
never dull
is it me or does that just say that she
dresses like a [__] hottie and we
stairs it towards sex no I'm reading the
rest of this yeah just read the rest of
it because then I wanna I wanna unload
Ayman I want to um no I'm I need to
unload okay I was told twice after my
friends broke their relationships off
with their girlfriends that their
girlfriends were jealous of me but what
do you expect of course we're gonna have
our inside jokes and lots in common
I have strong friendships and have known
my friends usually longer than they have
known their girlfriends I actually am
pretty lucky when it comes to guys I'm
always treated like a princess which I
adore of course partially because I'm
not a horny [__] who chooses hot guys
who are [__] just to [__] what's the
downside I'm not making this up the
downside of it all is I always feel bad
about the whole situation so bad about
the whole about the whole situation so I
never get into relationships myself so I
thought I would ask you for your
viewpoint in addition to my girlfriends
what's your opinion should I draw myself
back or go with the flow and then see
what happens
PS I know your answer is going to be
rude and biased but it's okay I get a
kick out of it what does that mean go
with her what it was that last sentence
I think I think she's talking about she
said back off go with the flow I think
she's talking about I can't tell if
she's talking about letting herself go
to get into a relationship or she should
back off her guy friends when they have
when they have girlfriends you know what
okay I have this to say to this girl and
I'm gonna refer to this person as a girl
because only a girl would be so
blatantly narcissistic and
and then have the balls to act like she
doesn't understand why the other girls
don't like her okay you know it's like
you know exactly what you're doing what
is she doing you're being a manipulative
little narcissus it has to be the center
of attention and the other girls know
that you're doing this that's why they
don't like you so we're not jealous of
you they see exactly the kind of girl
that you are and let me guess I mean
yeah you're the kind of girl that like I
don't really have like a lot of female
friends cuz like girls are [__] and
Michael backstab you can't with a guy
isn't have like a beer or whatever cuz I
don't care you know what I mean yeah
your was just she's one of those girls
and the reason that is is because you
are everything that most women hate but
you're too dumb to realize that you are
the one that's doing it let me guess
so you hang out with all these guys your
guy friends that are like confiding in
you and being oh so flirty with you
you're hanging around this guy but I
have a feeling that you suck out all the
air out of a room any time you're around
so whatever girl they're around
immediately hates you because we hate
women like you and you're throwing
around enough of a whiff of [__] to
have them follow you around because in
typical guy fashion some of them are
just too [__] stupid and they're
hanging on to this hope that you're
actually going to [__] them and you're
doing this because you even though
you're a narcissist you have all this
self-loathing like you don't feel like
you can get a good guy and I'm not
buying the I'm really lucky with guys
they treat me like princess and I adore
so why aren't you in a relationship why
don't you have a boyfriend why are you
always hanging out with other people's
boyfriends why don't you get your own
man
Jesus it works back the [__] off I'm
getting a pause rate on every talk show
all you needed to end that with it you
need to get a job stand girls like so
let me get let me ask you this okay she
casually throws out how she I'm no Megan
Fox but I have been compared to Katy
Perry [__] please
all right Nia everybody taking care of
that topic let me let me just if I can
just try to just if if she walks into a
bar and okay she's already in the bar
that's what I'm picturing she's already
in the bar or she shows up like if the
guys like oh my girlfriend are going
down for a [__] brunch you were gonna
watch the game
she comes down looks extra cute extra
[__] hot has it tits hanging out of
course and then deliberately does the
inside jokes yep to show that she's
closer to them she's that girl you know
she's borrowed one of their t-shirts and
wears them to one of these things yeah
yeah okay that's what I thought
I see see well see you know I can't even
believe that the nerve that that email
was even written what's the thing how
you trashed her was basically the angle
I was gonna trash her but I don't have
your insight as a female but what was
great about that was it just would have
been back-to-back meet trash in a female
I would have come off like an [__]
that was great you actually I feel like
I pulled a little sinister move there I
got you to do my dirty work oh is that
what you think that was tremendous you
[__] blew the pubes right off a
little landing strip that you know she's
accidentally showed with her lucid
[__] shorts
anyways overrated underrated overrated
bottled water somebody didn't say why
yeah I think it's overall I'd you know
that they just what well underwater I
think they just scooped it out of some
[__] pond I think and then they boil
it and they stick it into a goddamn yeah
probably and they leave in a warehouse
full of ever I've heard like years I've
heard from people who didn't really
investigate it I've overheard them
talking about it that they that they do
it everyone I'll tell you what the
problem is because it ends up in the
ocean like like I
what does the bottles yeah even though
you put them in the blue trash barrel
we're gonna recycle right you know you
know there's no money in recycling
really they haven't figured out how to
do it and I've seen so many of those
investigative reporters you know those
guys the reporters who actually do their
job and they give a [__]
yeah and they follow him the driver
driving like some 72 [__] Caprice
Classic with like the the [__]
driver's side door doesn't close unless
they tie it to the headrest and they
follow these [__] trucks and they
bring it to the dump they bring it to
dump oh and that some of that [__] ends
up in the ocean it's yeah so I don't
know and then they said underrated
meatloaf Oh meatloaf is awesome yeah I
think meatloaf is the [__] it is but you
know what if it's not made right then
it's really [__] terrible then it's
like a brick yeah
meatloaf meatloaf is like the Malcolm
young of meat it's just the [__] it's
the [__] and it's just totally not
appreciated now and everybody thinks
that it's simple like people like people
play guitar think what Malcolm young
does an ac/dc is a simple thing to play
something that's simple with that much
air in between it you know and get
80,000 people to absolutely lose their
[__] minds they think that it's
simple meatloaf is the same [__]
thing what do you what halo if everybody
thinks I can make [__] meat long have
you ever made oh yeah you have yeah I
have a recipe you know what the best
part of the recipe is at the very end
you take a strip of bacon and you put it
right I would love to me you know
something I actually believe it or not I
enjoy cooking but you cooked so well and
you do it for me
you know and I'm so busy you know fixing
the leaky faucet by the way did you
notice that the cold knob doesn't work
now what do you mean it doesn't yeah it
does no it doesn't go just go look oh no
no no no no the broken side works it
works but the other side doesn't know
what Apple did you do I was taking a
picture of it for my from my podcast to
show people what it looked like so I had
to turn it on so I just turned the water
off underneath
okay all you do is turn it
counterclockwise and I'll come back on
what do you remember when I fixed the
faucet I fixed the leaky faucet I don't
know what I did and this time I couldn't
do it and I let my temper get the best
of me
can you least tell my podcast listeners
how I at least compartmentalized my
temper right I don't lose my [__] in the
car anymore that's true that's gone oh
that was such an effort for you to give
me that that was such an effort it's
gotten better it's gotten a lot better I
used to be like
is there anything funnier than somebody
in a Prius with a [__] roid rage and
the fact that I'm a Red Hood
when I say roid rage yeah I'm a little
[__] tired today I've been I've been
[__] up all the words yeah the comedy
moments it's just gone
what else is overrated and underrated is
that it bottled water and meatloaf come
on
well that topic is just sort of
gradually dying I don't know why people
I think we've pretty much got everything
that's [__] over oh here's one fat
head of the week bringing this one back
John Cougar Mellencamp did I bring him
up before why did why what do you mean
I'm to Ike like I talked to people all
the time about [__] uh just you know
I quit boozing because I was getting
that big Ted Kennedy [__] head yeah
and John Cougar Mountain like John
Cougar Mellencamp doesn't whatever camp
his head's big enough for three names he
has a giant [__] squash now he was
riding on this Vespa ride on a Vespa
with [__] meg Ryan who got her face
did I don't know what she sees on the
street no I went to like oh my god
they're just like us dog collar I don't
know where I saw it
so she was peeking out behind with her
her cat eyes that she has now yeah she
did do you look like Madonna in a window
so she's peeking around his giant
[__] head maybe he was just the angle
now this Joe she has those she got the
bed she the crush I had on her did you
meg Ryan is your type but you have weird
tights and you talk about girls used to
crush on when you were younger its I'm
always surprised so Meg Ryan Mary Lou
Retton she had nice thighs she was a
little thick E I my mom was just like
she's a little she's a little bigger
it's like I like that all those other
gymnasts though running around looked
like little [__] poodles she did she
was Jo yeah she had a nice smile mm-hmm
little Dorothy Hamill haircut
she's very perky Wow she was I had some
ideas you want to hear my crush
America's my precious when I was a kid
let's see here the first one I can
remember was Kate Jackson when she was
on the road on the rookies okay one of
the great [__] theme songs
okay of all time Farrah Fawcett of
course who else Oh Valerie Bertinelli oh
yeah at a time I had a lot of hashes
then I cross the street when I started
watching Diff'rent Strokes and I like
the young Janet Jackson went across the
street yeah what did he call cross the
tracks it went into the when she played
was it not penny was good times I didn't
like she was a little fatty on that one
she needed to do some laps she needed to
run up and down this project stairs
that's baby fat anyways listen to me
that should have got a laugh but you
weren't listening
oh projects it from good times he lived
in the project wasn't project yes yeah
it was you weren't listening you were
too busy thinking about what you were
gonna say if you can do the radio thing
you have to listen to the other person
so how are you doing it huh I mean how
am i doing it I've heard everything
you've said I mean when you were on that
rant trashing that woman you think I
didn't have jokes to add to it I I was
like she's just let it go I was on a
fish on let her [__] wear herself out
now real er back into the boat that's
what I did so know when she's like
Charmaine when she played Charmaine
it was course Tonya Kitaen and in the
[__] Whitesnake video
huh yeah I like Blair for a minute but
then I ended up like in Joe the more
facts of life yeah the one who was in
the riding the motorcycle I was like
brunettes Oh Joe was hotter than Blair
are we having a slumber party what could
we start talking about this I just god
was sexy Eric it was higher Sex in the
City on laserdisc and I have to tell you
I am beyond excited I really was later
just good I bet it was [__]
phenomenal out for like two years and
then no one cared anymore
yeah like guys like Steven Spielberg
people who are already already made it
on that [__] you know he had all that
stuff probably played like 20 grand for
it to when he got it already got it for
free because of course he got it for
free what movie what movie was he doing
hook hook was a big hit all right so
here's the YouTube videos for the week
you'd love this one
this kid you know you know those little
pageant pageant girls you know that I'm
going to bay yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
somebody who actually got her talking
about getting hair spray in her mouth
and they slowed it down so she sounds
like a [__] hilarious these are all
gonna be up on the mmm podcast by the
way and if you want to go on the mmm
podcast and make a donation yes and to
help keep us running here with our
unbelievable overhead actually be giving
us money towards the new studio that I
hopefully I'll be getting soon yeah just
click on the donation button right on
the mm podcast com it's right underneath
the Facebook Twitter and all those
buttons right on the right-hand side of
the page and let's see here so you know
you know that they had those little kids
that the you know parents get him into
those beauty contests which is really
[__] creepy like why would you do
that after that John John John Bonnie
in the floor whatever some sort of
hockey name right baby
anyways so there's a boy who competes in
these things well he refers to himself
as a diva and I want yeah I know Jesus
and I want you to watch this because I
can't figure out if this kid needs a
father figure and to be rescued from his
mother his mother is either absolutely
crazy or the greatest [__] mom in
history because she's either figured out
that this kid is gay already she's
totally get up and she totally accepted
him which is beyond beyond [__] yes
with a little stage mom thrown in of
course yeah both because the she has
another kid and it's a little girl and
she's also in that pageant thing and I
found that parents who enter their kids
into those pageant things there were
little [__] nuts yeah there's
something a little [__] wrong with
putting a kid net kabuki makeup and
dress her up like a little [__]
harlot yeah now it's got to go with
she's a girl a red road trigger back in
the day with Roy Rogers what was classic
Hollywood way back in that from your
generation no no that's from way back
way back with what the [__] was Roy
Rogers the chicken guy right no is he a
cowboy Hollywood cowboy on the
California Angels okay well if it is
then [__] him he sold out alright we're
going on to the next one's got to make
money Sean Connery that classic clip I
remember this when I was a kid when he
went on Barbara Walters and he talked
about how he thought it wasn't a bad
thing to open hand slap your woman
that's right when she won't let it go
and you know as much as I could never do
that to you bill
I got to tell you there
the moments where I wish that we could
rewind society a few years you know we
could just what if I could just snap my
fingers and I was dressed like Robert
Fulton and I took off a glove and just
slapped you across the face and then
snap my finger we were right back into
the Prius and there was not a goddamn
thing he'd do about it cuz when I hit
you
it was 1850 Oh hair spray the mother oh
here's one for drummers out there Buddy
Rich watch this video now everybody as
far as I've known I've always given
credit to Tommy Lee for being the first
guy to do the the drumset movie this is
Buddy Rich from back in the day going
all the way upside down playing and is
something this is something I wouldn't
watch because this is really hippie man
man this is fish video video called you
enjoy myself the band yes with the pH
well this is actually really interesting
like this because I actually saw them
perform this song right like that's
there if you can get past their annoying
fans they're [__] a mate and the way
to get high with then the way they dance
that hit me dancing where you know you
just sort of like like all right like
anyways so this it's called you enjoy
myself for those of you who are into
like harder kind of music if you're a
musician you'll definitely able to
appreciate this I'm Oh imagine most
people won't be able to get through the
11 minutes of it but I actually saw them
perform this song live when they jump on
the little [__] trampolines and I was
blown away by them as musicians but I
found their fans I can't blame a hundred
percent of them because just for the
record the spin doctors were also blind
and this is this is like right at that
you know the spin doctors were cool for
about 30 35 minutes they came to the
Boston Garden oh god this is a [__]
story they came to the Boston Garden and
it was this
those four the WBC n I don't know I
don't know what but it was right when
all the alternative music came in so
fish headlined it was the spin doctors
and I'm gonna leave this open-ended and
if you guys want to hear this story
because I'm not going because I don't
name names on this podcast but if you'd
like to hear this story
I would say ask Robert Kelley to tell
the story he has a podcast basically a
sketch group for some reason they
decided it would be a good idea yes they
had the main stage and they had a small
stage yeah and on the main stage was a
huge band Phish spend doctors and
whoever the [__] else was there and then
they would have like these little
acoustic sets and out of nowhere they
had this sketch group go on that Bobby
Kelly may or may not know the rest of
the story it was it was not the right
environment and it was amazing because I
think one of the things that I
remembered when they were doing their
sketches I think that people didn't
realize that they were a sketch comedy
group I think that they thought they
were actually a group that was
advocating recycling and that they were
trying to collect empty water bottles
some of them partially full because when
they were doing their jokes people were
donating their plastic bottles and you
know what I did I stood there and
watched it alright um you probably
participated you jerk no I didn't I felt
horrible for him
I felt [__] horrible for because I
baby just go ahead now and if you like
my [__] red beard just suck my dick
now and I don't have anymore that that
[__] song is so [__] bad just when
you think it can't get any worse than he
goes he should have been shot with a
crossbow
don't say that okay I shouldn't say that
say that he's a fellow redhead too
and he looked eerily like that other guy
who was on the US soccer team at that
time what was that other song something
about a [__]
was just [__] [__] been gone Little
Miss Little Miss enemies can't be yes
and that song I'm a [__] I'm gonna end
with this this is one of my old jokes
one of my original jokes that are you
pointing at me because you just reminded
me of something that song that song I'm
a [__] of that and all the women love
that song yeah that was one of my first
decent jokes I had because that song
came out all the women used to go nuts
singing that song I and I said I love
when that song comes on because you can
watch all the loser chicks trying to
pretend they have control of their life
and then they would always groan and I
would plow through the groan and be like
I go it's kind of like when that song I
the tiger comes on and every guy in the
bar starts throwing [__] punches like
there's something something so I kind of
brought it around and actually have to
piss and the women off would get them
back on my side and I remember thinking
like oh that's kind of a cool little
trick piss him off makes him pay
attention and then you give him the
punch line you make it seem like oh I'm
going over here but now I'm all I'm all
on this side of the stage wow it's so
Machiavellian who's have you been
reading the art of war you know
something I don't need to be belittled
on my own [__] podcast right yes you
do no you don't you know what that's a
classic female [__] thing now I'm
gonna end trashing women this is what
you guys do you love us your supporters
but the second you see is feeling good
about ourselves I don't know I think
subcontinent's you start seeing us feel
good about ourselves you get a little
insecure like oh my god he's gonna feel
good about himself and what is he gonna
do is he gonna leave me and think he can
do better let me [__] reel him in a
little bit here so yeah he had to bring
me down right there I was telling you a
story about yes you did no I didn't he
said all right now
I will leave it with dead okay well that
was my paranoia yes all right our in ten
minutes I think that's a that's a good
place to stop our in ten minutes
our tennis guys please help me fix this
sink if you know any places out here
that has vintage stuff where I can buy I
haven't it's very easy and everybody I'm
gonna love about it is everybody's gonna
come and help me out but they're going
to help me out in an internet way which
is they're going to be calling me a
[__] [__]
the entire time they help me yeah they
like that they'll be like this subject
we hey [__] alright [__] face this
next time you do this if you can [__]
figure it out more right they have to
like get in there so they can be like
once again once again bringing me down
rather than laughing you immediately do
you have something the hyper you're
going to be selling some sort of nia
merchandise I think it's very annoying
but I just feel like they're trying to
like be like you they're trying to
emulate you that's what I was trying to
say do you ever think that there's just
a bunch of Me's out there these people
would be doing I go on YouTube look what
people write under the videos out of
their [__] mind listen you got to
keep your face near the microphone if
you start doing stuff like this on the
podcast yeah you do that I'm not no no
you were talking and you started looking
down at your foot you went like that oh
I'm trying I'm trying to give you some
sort of mic skills because I think
you're you add a lot to the podcast and
I would like to offer you a contract to
be on here to work free as I do to be on
here more often well bring you in you
know something when I feel like like you
know what I feel like I curse too much
onstage when I'm really feeling that
like I literally have a taste in my
mouth like okay I need to clean it up a
little bit and like today when I was
trashing women to the levels just like
Jesus Christ I got to get I got to get
me in here to try to balance this out
and why I love you is you [__] I pass
the baton right to you and you took it
across the finish line thank you sweetie
[__] destroyed that lady yeah alright
that's the podcast so sort of a feel
good ending all right come on our selves
don't make it nice go [__] yourselves
that's the [__] that's for this week
I'll be talking to you guys next week
where am I gonna be this week
oh I'll be up in San Jose at the improv
and you got pick your microphone up you
just really killed that right there you
sent your microphone down and it rolls
and you can hear it oh yeah do you get
that it's on let me turn it off anyways
I'm gonna be up the sing the Improv in
San Jose you should definitely come out
to these shows because these are gonna
be monster shows because I have not done
an hour of stand-up in a while and I am
[__] chomping at the bit to do it and
I feel like unloading some brand new
[__] thoughts up there so please come
down to the scary downtown San Jose area
somebody got shot right out in front of
that place last time I really shouldn't
be bringing that up no you shouldn't
yeah I keep it real son I'm sure it was
all dealt with everything was they swept
it right up to the garden hose sprayed
the blood off and we did the second show
okay everything's okay yeah so please
come out to that next week I'm gonna be
down in Irvine Orange County the plastic
surgery capital of the world oh you're
gonna bring it there you know bring it
to them again are you gonna tell them
about themselves like you did last time
I'm gonna [__] rent a Dodge
Challenger and I'm gonna beat on that
driving to and from and cuz the highways
out here suck and then after that I'm at
the Montreal Comedy Festival and you
know there's gonna come yeah why don't
you go on that that Star Trek website
get yourself a cheap ticket all right
the one Captain Kirk talks about Oh
Priceline why don't you on that one I I
don't know because you usually come to
the the I don't know Miami I don't know
I don't talked about the ones you
usually go to you usually don't go to
that go to that one do I bring you to
that one why'd you make it awkward I
didn't I don't think you're going to
that one oh yeah no you're not going to
that one
alright alright that's the podcast for
this week I'll talk to you guys next
week and like I said if you guys if
you're watching anything I'd really like
to get some audio clips on this thing if
you see something on TV that strikes you
as funny send them in for God's sakes
alright
[Music]